>>> IN OUR POLITICS LEAD THE FBI
IS INVESTIGATING CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY THE
EMPLOYEES OF POSTMASTER GENERAL
LOUIS DEYOI TO REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES.
EMBROILED IN CONTROVERSY EVER
SINCE HE TOOK OFFICE IN MAY
2020, GIVING $1.1 MILLION TO
TRUMP'S RE-ELECTION CAMPAIGN AND
ONCE HE WAS IN OFFICE REDUCED
OVERTIME AND PUT LIMITS ON MAIL
TRIPS FOR MAIL CARRIERS WHICH
LED TO MASSIVE MAIL DELAYS IN
THE LEAD-UP TO THE 2020 ELECTION
WHEN, OF COURSE, A
RECORD-BREAKING NUMBER OF
AMERICANS WERE VOTING BY MAIL
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC,
DISPROPORTIONATELY DEMOCRATS
VOTING BY MAIL.
DEJOY WAS ACCUSED OF TRYING TO
SECRETLY SABOTAGE THE ELECTION.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THESE
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS BY HIS
STAFFERS AND HOW UNUSUAL IS
THAT?
>> WELL, JAKE, IF PROVEN TO BE
TRUE, IT WILL BE HIGHLY UNUSUAL
AND, FRANKLY, INAPPROPRIATE.
HERE IS WHAT WE KNOW SO FAR.
THIS APPEARS TO BE FOLLOWING
REPORTS LAST FALL THAT CITED
FORMER EMPLOYEES OF DEJOY'S,
MOST OF THEM ANONYMOUSLY
SPEAKING THAT SAYING WHILE
WORKING FOR DEJOY THEY FELT
URGED TO AND SOMETIMES PRESSURED
TO DONATE TO REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES AND THOSE WHO DID
ACTUALLY RECEIVED MONEY BACK IN
THE FORM OF BONUSES.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT DEJOY
VEHEMENTLY DENIES.
MR. DEJOY HAS LEARNED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
INVESTIGATING CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY EMPLOYEES
WHO WORKED FOR HIM WHEN HE WAS
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
HE HAS BEEN SCRUPULOUS IN HIS
ADHERENCE TO CAMPAIGN LAWS AND
HAS NEVER KNOWINGLY VIOLATED
THEM.
ONE THING TO NOTE HERE, WE KNOW
DEYOI IS A BIG-TIME REPUBLICAN
DONOR.
HE WAS A TRUMP MEGA DONOR.
ALL OF THIS IS HIGHLY SUSPECT.
AND SOMETHING WE HAVE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT FOR A LONG TIME.
NOW, OF COURSE, WE KNOW IT'S
UNDER A FORMAL INVESTIGATION.
>> IS THERE ANY CHANCE HERE THAT
DEJOY WOULD LOSE HIS POSITION AS
POSTMASTER GENERAL, WHICH WOULD
BE VERY DIFFICULT FOR HIM TO BE
FORCED OUT?
>> YEAH, THAT'S ALWAYS THE BIG
QUESTION, JAKE.
OF COURSE, WE KNOW PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN CALLING FOR HIS OUSTER NOW
FOR ROUGHLY A YEAR.
THE THING THAT'S IMPORTANT NOTE
IS THAT THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO CAN
REMOVE DEJOY FROM OFFICE ARE THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
POSTAL SERVICE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS.
FOR ALL THE ALLEGATIONS THROUGH
THE ELECTION, WE HAVE HEARD FROM
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS SAYING
THEY HAVE FULL CONFIDENCE IN
DEJOY.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO INDICATION
THAT HAS SHIFTED.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS ADDED MORE
PEOPLE TO THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS.
HOWEVER, IN ORDER TO ACTUALLY
OUST DEJOY, THEY HAVE TO GET
SOME OF THOSE TRUMP-APPOINTED,
TRUMP-NOMINATED MEMBERS TO SIGN
UP FOR THAT.
AGAIN, THERE'S NO INDICATION OF
THAT.
THE PRESS SECRETARY WAS ASKED
WHETHER OR NOT BIDEN BELIEVED
THAT DEJOY SHOULD BE REMOVED OR
REPLACED AND UNSURPRISING LY, SE
DODGED THE QUESTION, SAYING HE
WOULD LIKE THE INVESTIGATION TO
JUST PLAY OUT.
AGAIN, IT IS ULTIMATELY GOING TO
BE UP TO THAT BOARD OF
GOVERNORS.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE WHERE THIS
INVESTIGATION GOES.
>> ABBY PHILIP JOINS ME NOW IN
STUDIO.
AS KRISTEN JUST NOTED, BIDEN
CAN'T REMOVE DEJOY.
IT'S UP TO THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS.
DEMOCRAT OF NEW JERSEY WROTE A
LETTER TO THE THREE BIDEN
APPOINTEES THAT HE ADDED TO THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS, URGING THEM
TO VOTE DEJOY OUT, ADDING HE'S
CORRUPT TO THE CORE, DEJOY.
SELF-INFLICTED NATIONWIDE DELAYS
J
JUSTLY WARRANT HIS EXPEDITIOUS
REMOVAL SO THAT THE BOARD MAY
APPOINT IN HIS PLACE A QUALIFIED
AND COMPETENT POSTMASTER GENERAL
PREPARED TO LEAD WITH BOLD
SOLUTIONS TO SAVE OUR POST
OFFICE.
>> DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
PUSH DEJOY OUT FOR A LONG TIME.
THESE ALLEGATIONS, THOUGH NOW
BEING INVESTIGATED BY THE DOJ,
HAVE BEEN OUT THERE SINCE LAST
SUMMER.
SO A LOT OF THIS HAS BEEN KNOWN
ABOUT THE QUESTIONS BEING RAISED
AROUND THE POLITICAL DONATIONS.
AND I DON'T NECESSARYILY SEE THS
CHANGING THE DYNAMIC.
ONE OF THE TENETS OF TRUMPISM,
IF YOU BELIEVE LOUIS DEJOY IS A
TRUMPER, YOU DON'T BACK DOWN,
STEP DOWN, YOU DON'T GIVE ANY
QUARTER TO THESE KINDS OF
ALLEGATIONS SO I WOULDN'T EXPECT
HIM TO DO THAT.
>> LET'S CHANGE THE SUBJECT.
I WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE ON DANA
B
BASH'S NEW REPORTING THAT FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, QUOTE, MORE
OBSESSED THAN EVER WITH THE 2020
ELECTION, UNQUOTE, AND IS ONLY
LISTENING TO, QUOTE, THE BOTTOM
OF THE BOTTOM OF THE CRAZIES IN
THE BARREL, UNQUOTE, ACCORDING
TO A FORMER TRUMP AIDE.
THIS IS NEVER GOING TO END, IS
IT?
>> I FEEL WE'VE BEEN HAVING SOME
FORM OF THIS REPORTING FOR FOUR
YEARS.
THIS IS A FORMER PRESIDENT
CONSTANTLY SCRAPING FROM THE
BOTTOM OF THE BARREL IN TERMS OF
THE PEOPLE HE KEEPS AROUND HIM,
THE CONSPIRACY THEORIES HE
FOSTERS AND HIS OBSESSION WITH
NOT LOSING OR NOT BEING WILLING
TO ACCEPT HIS LOSS IS A DEFINING
CHARACTERISTIC OF WHO HE IS AS A
PERSON.
SO, NO, IT'S NOT GOING TO GO
AWAY.
IN FACT, IT'S ONLY GOING TO GET
WORSE.
AND THE DISTURBING THING ABOUT
THIS IS THAT THIS IS SOMEONE WHO
IS BECOMING EVEN MORE UNHINGED
AND DISTURBED FROM REALITY.
AND THIS IS THE PERSON WHO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS DECIDED IS
THE LEADER OF THEIR PARTY.
THEY CAN'T EVEN DEFEND THIS
STUFF.
THEY'RE JUST CLAIMING THEY
HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT IT.
THE REALITY IS THAT HE'S LIVING
IN AN ALTERNATIVE UNIVERSE WHEN
IT COMES TO THE 2020 ELECTION
AND REPUBLICANS ARE JUST TURNING
THE OTHER WAY.
REPUBLICANS IN WASHINGTON.
>> YEAH.
AND, I MEAN, WITH DEADLY
RESULTS.
THE JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION.
WE'VE SEEN THREATS.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE OF
ARIZONA WAS JUST HERE, TALKING
ABOUT THE THREATS TO HER.
TRUMP IS ALSO ALLEGEDLY
SPREADING THE LIE THAT HE IS
GOING TO BE REINSTATED IN
AUGUST.
LET ME MAKE THAT CLEAR.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING.
ACCORDING TO CHARLES COOK,
WRITING IN "THE NATIONAL
REVIEW," QUOTE, TRUMP IS TRYING
HARD TO RECRUIT JOURNALISTS,
POLITICIANS AND INFLUENTIAL FOLK
S NOT AS A TRIAL BALLOON BUT AS
A FACT, UNQUOTE.
SO, SPEAKING OF FACTS, HE'S NOT
GOING TO BE REINSTATED.
SENATOR PURDUE IS NOT GOING TO
BE REINSTATED.
SENATOR McSALLY WILL NOT BE
REINSTATED.
IT'S ALL NUTS.
CHARLES' REPORTING, HE HAS
ACTUALLY LOST HIS MARBLES IS
WHAT HE'S SAYING.
>> BASICALLY.
AND THE REASON THAT CHARLES COOK
WROTE THAT IN THE NATIONAL
REVIEW FOR THOSE WHO ARE
LISTENING, IT'S A CONSERVATIVE
PUBLICATION, IS TO ALERT
CONSERVATIVES WHAT IS DIFFERENT
ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS NOT JUST, YOU KNOW,
TRUMP BEING TRUMP.
THIS IS NOT JUST TRUMP TROLLING.
THIS IS TRUMP ESPOUSING BELIEFS
THAT ARE ANTI-DEMOCRATIC IN
NATURE.
HE MAKES POINT THAT THAT SAY
COMPLETELY -- A FORMER
PRESIDENT, A CURRENT PRESIDENT
SHOULD BELIEVE IN THE TENETS OF
DEMOCRACY AND THE IDEA THAT ONE
COULD BE REINSTATED AFTER LOSING
A FREE AND FAIR ELECTION IS NOT
IN ACCORDANCE WITH DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S THE POINT OF THIS BEING
PUT OUT THERE FOR CONSERVATIVES
TO READ.
THE QUESTION IS, ARE THEY
LISTENING?
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE NOT
AT THIS POINT.
THEY THINK IT'S MORE OF THE
SAME.
THIS IS DIFFERENT.
HE IS DISCONNECTED FROM THE
REALITY OF THE SITUATION.
>> FOX HAS LET GO OF SOME PEOPLE
WHO PUSHED BACK ON THE LIE,
INCLUDING ONE OF THEIR POLITICAL
DIRECTORS.
>> YEAH.
>> PEOPLE AT THE DECISION DESK.
>> THEY ARE PART OF THAT
CONSPIRACY.
THEY'RE BUYING INTO IT.
>> FOX IS, YEAH.
>> AND WILL BE RESPONSIBLE.